ALL RIGHT, NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
KILLER B'S.
>> Chris: BACK IN THE 1970S
AND 1980S BEFORE WITH THE
WORLD'S ACCUMULATED KNOWLEDGE
WAS AT OUR FINGERTIPS AT ALL
TIMES, WE HAD VHS TAPES.
OR TAH-PES. I AM NOT SURE IF I
AM PRONOUNCING THAT PROPERLY.
THEY WERE USED FOR EVERYTHING
FROM RECORDING TV SHOWS TO
MAKING AMATEUR PORNOGRAPHY.
WELL, THE INCREDIBLE TUMBLR VHS
NINJA COLLECTS RETRO COVER ART
FOR VIDEOTAPES OF OLD
B-MOVIES.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A B-MOVIE'S
VHS BOX ART,
AND FOR 250 POINTS YOUR JOB IS
TO PITCH ME THAT MOVIE.
FIRST UP, THE NIGHT OF A
THOUSAND CATS.
>> THE NIGHT OF A ONE
>> Chris: WHAT?
>> A ONE THOUSAND CATS.
>> OH, MY WORD.
>> I LOVE THE SEQUEL, WHICH IS
THE NIGHT OF A 1,000 CATS REGAIN
FRIENDSHIP.
100 POINTS TO KEVIN SMITH FOR
THAT.
>> OKAY, ANYONE PITCH ME
THIS MOVIE. SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> THEY CAN ONLY BE DEFEATED BY
A ONE THOUSAND VACUUMS.
>> Chris: ROBERT KIRKMAN.
>> HERE'S THE TAGLINE: "HERE
KITTY, KITTY, KITTY, KITTY,
KITTY, KITTY, KITTY, KITTY."
I GOT TO DO IT ONE
THOUSAND TIMES.
>> Chris: THAT'S OKAY.
KRISTEN WILL WATCH IT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: YES, SHE WILL.
POINTS TO KIRKMAN.
KEVIN SMITH.
>> SO MUCH PUSSY, SO LITTLE
LASAGNE.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE, HERE IS A TAUT CRIME
DRAMA.
"TOP SQUAD."
ROBERT KIRKMAN.
>> ABOUT A FEMALE COP WHO NO ONE
WILL TAKE SERIOUSLY UNTIL SHE
LEARNS HOW TO WEAR WITH A SHIRT.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
NOT REALLY AN ACTION FILM.
IT'S REALLY A DISCOVERY.
>> Chris: KEVIN SMITH.
>> I AM GOING TO SAY IT'S SHIRTS
VERSUS SKINS,
AND THE SCALES OF JUSTICE ARE
TOPLESS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES.
SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> HEY, HER EYES ARE UP HERE.
AND SO ARE HER TITS.
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS.
MOVING ON, SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
SEDUCTIVE AND DEADLY, "NINJA
QUEEN BOXER!" SCOTT.
>> THE BAFFLING SEQUEL TO
"SCHINDLER'S LIST."
IT'S THE GIRL IN THE RED DRESS.
>> Chris: ROBERT KIRKMAN.
>> ABOUT A FEMALE NINJA WHO NO
ONE WILL TAKE SERIOUSLY UNTIL
SHE LEARNS HOW TO WEAR WITH A
SHIRT.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
KEVIN SMITH.
>> NINJA, QUEEN, BOXER: THE
HILLARY CLINTON STORY.
>> Chris: OKAY.
POINTS.